[Music]
coming at you live from the roof of the
Spreckels theater in downtown San Diego
it's live at Conan Cod featuring
comedians Joel Kim booster Flula Borg
and marina Franklin and now you're live
at Conan Con host Moses store hello and
welcome to live at Kona Con I'm the
world's lowest paid cam boy
Moses storm I like nudity and I hate
doing favors if you're not already make
sure you're following live at Kona con
that's our insert where we're posting
all things that Conan is doing down here
at Comic Con in addition to that I have
my very funny correspondents who are out
there on the streets of the con grabbing
all the stuff that in case you guys
couldn't come and you're missing out
we're there we're on the streets we'll
be checking in with them in a little bit
these are my correspondents please say
hello to the very funny marina Franklin
the impossibly charming Flula Borg you
stopped at Moses storm and the man that
just doesn't quit that's barely a
compliment but Joakim booster Joakim
booster guys thank you so much for
joining us once again you guys were out
there all day yes super tired uh how are
we feeling I feel great
yeah yesterday stream was just it was
just a tryptophan mess yes but today we
got a nice reset yes letting a little
bit later in the day no one's screaming
from from rooftops try yet and I can
already see the comments section
lighting up because everyone asks
where's Conan it's a great question
hurts my feelings every time more for
your Kodokan thing please welcome Conan
O'Brien about 3000 people here right
would you say I'll just come over here
it's Joel do you mind if I sit next to
you I see well good to see you and then
of course here as well kkona doing a
great job so much like peppermint I want
to say I the disparity the
difference between the show that I just
taped yeah there's 4,000 people in the
crowd and I descended on wire yeah I
don't wanna give away too much because
it doesn't air tonight it airs tomorrow
night right here with the just settle
down you mean weird if that was no smart
no and you're wearing cranberry running
you know jeans and you're not weird I
can do that bird running push my leg oh
my god make a pop no if we do both it's
sexual like a ratchet wrench is that
it's supposed to this must be little
clicks buzzes but anyway so much energy
yes and I rush up the stairs wipe the
makeup off forgot about this ran up the
stairs and then you come out and it's a
it's a tarpaper roof
yeah and it's silent except for the hum
of a nearby air conditioner can I show
you something no on this we can't get a
shot of this but what it says it says
tapas I see that it's a pas and there's
a tapa restaurant below the theater that
blows their exhaust air directly into
our set smells good actually it's
getting I'm getting I'm getting bacon
yeah I'm getting pork mm-hmm I'm getting
I think I'm getting a rice I think I'm
doing a sauteed rice some basmati what
did you say to me well I said it's a
form of rice basmati no okay I thought
you accused me of some horrible crime
sorry
I don't mean any mean to snap at you flu
let's fine let it happen
yeah but there's a hot top of air and
you can really notice the 10 minute mark
of the show that it really starts to
kick in and people really start to just
have to take a dive on the couch listen
I I think next year we get some people
up here on the way out to create an
energy but I kind of like this now
because there's these dead spots oh yeah
in these quiet moments intimate well I
was gonna use the word eerie eerie
deeply disturbing and haunting yeah
chilling I think comedy works best when
you have no immediate feedback for
what's funny and what's not that's
personally the way I like to do it I
like to do all my sets in a separate
room yes yeah away from the audience
okay the entire time we were talking I
was hearing the hum of the tapas machine
yeah it is insane down there I've come
to a few of the tapings in in Los
Angeles yes
and those are obviously pretty high
energy too but you come here in the
comic-con crowd is especially nice it's
a beautiful theater these sprinkles
theater they pack it and very hard to
get a ticket I think I get 50,000
requests why are you yelling at me why
that woman is making she's making a sign
to you to do something what is he doing
Ronny to take off my dress like the
table it's funny I'm just gonna let the
home viewer know that a woman in a
headset waved like this yet pointed at
Moses and now your matches take off your
top imagine going on without your
supervision up here they've just been
bullying us to take off and then the top
no no no no no top by the bottoms
bottoms bottom spot too much yellow to
show you need to supervise this
remembered I was on an ice floe this
woman interrupted it very necessary task
if you switching your wardrobe out does
that make the show better top what are
our streams up to now do we have six
that's not funny you just put this thing
down and I think you guys are doing a
great job if you say oh six streaming
when it's up towards the nines or the
tens is insulting not just to me but to
everyone it doesn't matter how much to
Flula but it's true yeah these
hard-working comics right here well it's
just I am I've yelled at the crew to
keep a single on me so that's why the
streams have been going down I am blown
away by the crowds here and tonight we
had an amazing show as I said it's going
to air tomorrow night
smart M night Shyamalan Bruce Willis
samuel l.jackson incredible lineup Jamie
Lee Curtis Jamie Lee that's a surprise
that's mine it's fine it's line got
briefed here from off camera they're
asking you give yourself a haircut was
busy picking the thing that most the
quote that most look like a fruit
wrap-up comparing his legs
that's what Kay Joel it was this fun
rise for the fans dangerous anyway
that's a really fun bit yeah there's a
lot coming at you tomorrow it's gonna be
a lot of fun how long were you before
the show star how dare you ask me a
question yes mister I have been in this
business for you know over 65 years I
will make hand signals
open hand means ask me a question closed
hand means I continue talking how long
were you in the rafters
mr. O'Brien I was in the rafters for a
fun stunt that we're gonna do on
tomorrow night's show I was up there I
think for four hours okay and I had a
lot of time alone obviously I was up
there for a little while they had to get
me up into the roof of the theater and I
was up there alone and this woman is
very she's taking control of the show
she's the most powerful woman in the
digital space worldwide right now is
this woman who's he who just looked at
me and one like this you and then she
went one and then she made oh then you
close your mouth no I can see here all I
want what do I have to go anyway who are
you what are you talking down the show
and we're we have to make we have to go
Conan's being bumped by a passing pigeon
it wants to roost here and we have to
make way for it this survivor you I will
no I will not don't wrap me listen when
I want to be wrapped yeah I give you one
of these and then it up and down okay
hold it now ask me a question okay what
is your favorite part about being on a
roof and why wouldn't you do your own
show on a roof my favorite part is
seriously the odors of the tapas fresh
breeze it's not as hot as it was last
year never landed yes last year's deaf
you punk kids you have it easy
and you with your fanny pack hello you
you know think you have everything
you're so materialistic and you need it
all close to your crotch all your
possessions
[Applause]
please see something should I show you a
tiny bit quickly the table here for
calling emergencies that's everyone has
one of these and it's there it's a phone
you don't just use you need a whole
fanny pack for you're just sure yes I
don't have I don't know is it is it I
don't know the etiquette and I'm listen
what I just did coat I want you to all
to talk about it yourselves I don't know
I respect people's personal space and I
apologize if that was wrong
no out of time but is it wrong to know
your hand in there and reach around for
that okay so you're fine okay yes
goodness that's gonna come we're getting
it okay from the director of the roof
that that's fine for you to read me hand
in there I love it up here you know what
I'm happier up here then I'd been in the
last 15 years
I seriously since 2003 it's everything
he's making it he's making the show too
old that's what she's saying camera on
that one step out here for a second so I
would be around to be seen but God see
this is our this is Carmen you're very
lovely very Carmen listen you are
abusive you you I come up here and I'm
you know at least among like six people
in the world somewhat of a legend and
you just kicked me around like I was
nothing
you played hacky sack with my ass you
kicked me around you treated me like I
was just a piece of dirt when I was when
you're not interested my story anymore
you cut me off and then you sent me
packing and I loved it it was very cool
I liked it like a man for Conan to pick
you up
there's men and white jackets they're
asking you to leave oh it's very strong
no they're very hostile no great bye
I thought the fruit roll very much then
I reached in there and touched me yes
marina is the only person he's been nice
to all day a man fits inside it's a peg
we doing are promoting safety good very
good thank you I'm gonna go I'm gonna
drift this way okay good this bump this
bottom but that can't talk if you keep
the fist closed and then this means have
a seat have a seat and continue the show
oh it's wherever your plan fusing okay
so he Conan's gonna be wandering the
satis for the for the rest of the show
keep the keep the streams up you can I
just want to give a quick shout out to
our friends at DirecTV that are making
this entire show possible so our friends
at DirecTV now we're bringing you
insider access to your favorite
comic-con things if you're tired of
being trapped in smothering year-long
contracts and if the Cable Guy stomping
into your house while he installs some
bulky hardware just so you could watch
your favorite show
well DirecTV now is a dish free with no
annual contract no bulky DirecTV now
lets you watch your must-have
of live TV shows anywhere from wherever
you are have 10 or 11 hours to kill
while you wait in line no problem with
Direct TV now you can stream your
favorite shows right from where you are
wherever you are and that weight type
will go by in no time could there be any
more distractions but there's no
distractions with Direct TV because
they're bringing you everything no
matter what you like DirecTV now has
more for your thing more for your life
at Kona con thing cuz I'm tight I got
that okay you did it oh you killed it
today my millionaire boss wandering
around that in the background you've
ever done that commercial though really
I think what commercial are you talking
about we're just a couple of teens
hanging out that's right okay teen you
were down at comic-con I was I didn't
make it down today yeah I decided I woke
up and I said you know what I want to do
today I want to go to comic-con yeah you
were full swing today I would say
Friday's probably like the big day yeah
it was intense it was crazy what's the
first thing you did you went to some
experience well yeah there's all the
Star Wars people were out I was really
excited I got to go and experience the
Millennium Falcon I met some fans it was
a it was a real dope day for me okay I
think I have some footage of that so
more for your comic-con on the floor
thing let's take a look at Joel hey guys
Joel here I am here with three die-hard
Star Wars fans and I have a question
who's your favorite British brunette in
the franchise
felicity Jill yes love that North I'm
talking about the stunt
is that there's a tiny little Phoebe
Waller bridge trapped inside the nav
computer for that station for Dan great
there's water in the back some some
Twizzlers if you want and I got a little
aux cord if you need to charge oh you
have a droid sorry we were just chatting
thank you what a what a great is a
really important that was a big if I
were if twelve-year-old me yeah that was
an increasing inside like it was as
probably as close to an actual prop from
the movie as it could be and it was
really really cool I will say that's the
darkest part of solo is the fact which
my set Phoebe Waller / spoiler alert
Phoebe Waller bridges droid character as
like oh this is a fully sentient being
and then yeah she dies and their
solution is to upload her consciousness
forever into the Millennium Falcon and
now we just know that she's inside
trapped like a an awful episode of black
mirror just stuck inside the Millennium
Falcon forever so even in like when
Daisy Ridley finds this piece of junk
you think it'll fly that's her body yeah
she's in hell that's an ending that is a
hell yeah escape for her I have to
imagine the Gimli didn't trap yeah to
detail teeny intention to did the
darkest details of that she's been
waiting I gotta say it didn't pick up on
that because you were one of the seven
people that saw the solo my guys are
savaging solo this week to say it's well
deserved it was it's not like an indie
movie where you can be like oh well they
need all the help they can get it was a
movie
well how much well I guess the show's
been ragging on it I don't know solo was
bad it was clear that there were 17
directors and 19 writers go and see it
with your movie pass yeah have you ever
gotten picked up by a piece of junk
uber oh yeah well I am NOT never ubers
but if you take lifts sometimes that you
tell the standards are a little bit
different do you like lifts a little bit
cheaper direct sponsor I got picked up
by like a Pontiac Sunfire and I was like
how do they even make the coolest
current car are you
I think Flula was the lyft driver I was
yeah voice of the lyft driver
I was the what's-her-name Pharoahe Monch
what's the voice inside the Millenium
bird VB well anyway she's not a voice
though she's just a consciousness living
inside the NASA computer did you meet
Chewbacca today I didn't meet any
Chewbacca's well you did meet someone I
know right did I did
I met a star of Wimbledon paul bettany
paul bettany comic-con people would
probably know him from the avenger from
french Wimbledon Wimbledon yeah also
actually started also in solo okay he
plays the villain in solo as well okay
joking all the celebrities I think I
actually have a photo of that so let's
see yep that is a picture he was so kind
you i we were staging this photo and
Isaac you don't know me you don't have
to touch me and he was like no I want to
touch you and I was like well now I feel
uncomfortable because you see he seemed
really hell-bent on touching me in the
photo but this we are this was part of
the Avengers hug bus hug but yeah
because so again spoiler alert I've been
talking I've been spoiling every major
movie in the last six months everyone
dies in the Avengers half the planet
disappears okay and it's very sad Tom
Holland disappears I don't think they're
gonna bring any of them back either I
really do think that true but a lot of
people needed counseling so Marvel was
kind enough to provide grief counselors
for figure and Comic Con to give people
a little lift to grieve these fictional
characters because there's really
nothing more tragic no there's nothing
else going on in the world be concerned
about greatness important I think 50% of
the population yeah disappearing is the
real problem and you know what Thanos
was right that was all for more for your
sci-fi thing and Flula I understand that
yesterday
well the first day you were down here
you showed up literally didn't didn't
get into the comic-con yes kind of the
assignment was like please get out there
for people that did miss comic-con or
can't make it yes let's show them what's
going on I did this that's more of a
reminding people for what this show is
clappy block why is it Carter this is
like a touchdown essentially on all
things comic-con yes so you were out
there and then eventually you you I mean
did you get further today well in day
one I discovered there are doors but
they were not open and then the day two
I discovered their lines but I did not
know what to do with their lines okay
and then day what is today 3 3 today is
day 3 today 3 I spoke with people who
are standing into the lines and I try to
maybe they can help me a little bit ok
so more for your comic-con thing let's
take a look at fluo in I guess line ok
because what's this like for
[Music]
it's a secret excuse me do you know what
this line is for
what's this line for
[Music]
excuse me what's this yeah thank you I
like I like
[Laughter]
okay yeah was that second the last thing
was that a zombie or is that just a San
Diego native I think both Cinco so he
dropped his private license on the way
as he was drooling away from me he did
drive and you saw a chatty ago and then
I said would you like it back and then
he said well you're getting closer and
closer every day I think by the last day
Sunday you might make it to just the
front of the line the front then I can
go inside what is that on your on your
head
Oh am I just happy to see you nope what
what are you asking that orange thing on
your head do you approach those whales
in the photo for yeah I said it as if it
was currently on my cabeza I'm sorry
cabeza is that another word for head I
have learned some Spanish in my days
okay it means head in Spanish I have no
way about it but I'm so suspicious I
wish we aren't weren't also ignorant
yeah I feel in my bones that that's
wrong I feel like that's a desert it
could be by makeup woman just shook her
head and said some people here some
people eat heads give it up for dead
space yeah I know I love this so I mean
you gotta look a little better response
once you started dressing up yes I
learned they will ignore you if they
think oh you're not part of our team you
know it's like if you are playing for
the Clippers but then you are wearing a
Yankee Jersey they won't pass you the
ball different really different sport
oh okay maybe that's why it's so sort of
works because he was dressed up he was
just dressed up in like Michael Jackson
backup dancer cosplay today yeah yeah I
think yours is even better your fashions
even better
thank you everybody looks look at this
look today yeah hello don't call this
look my best life I think we're in
Three's Company okay and you're Janet Oh
Janet no I ain't Janet copy Janet you
can be Jan okay
works hashtag Flula Janet Janet all
pulled together by the fanny pack all
the way the centerpiece of any Flula
look it's this like the Sun is the
center of our solar system
oh the fanny pack is the center of my
wardrobe okay we are heliocentric
universe everything of all yes valves
around the center yeah it's a nice purse
back thank you I think I think you with
your fanny pack you able to solve one of
the major problems at at comic-con yes
my angry stuff mugging yeah need to be a
very confident mugger mug someone in a
fanny pack we can't really pickpocket no
a fanny pack because like boom is up
with you right there I'm up here and I'm
going tiny tiny German wallet yeah
efficiency it's like two pieces of
chocolate in a money clip yeah but it's
not chocolate because it would match
because this is our very warm as
everyone knows okay so I have more of
your old merch thing fluids got a I
guess they unpacking like a unboxing
video but with the fanny packs
yes let's say that hey through an idea
and comic-con and i got your merch thing
all in my nice fanny let's see what we
have
Oh a smiling thing right
Oh a kitty hello and also
[Music]
it's a mullet that is a big mm I made it
myself
it does look like a dirty piece that
fell off of a mop it was a tent it was a
four person tent and the orange thing
that you pulled out I found I don't know
where I found that like something we
love well after when I was wearing the
mullet yes I became very warm that shirt
though there's no way to be hot in that
shirt that's almost like that's the most
modest lingerie
yeah I've ever seen it's like full body
coverage it's nice to have your nipples
exposed sometimes and still not you
still receive service at the counter you
know yes yeah des technically be wearing
a shirt yes in place that says no
nipples shorts and you're like oh well
fine I see yours but here's your burger
still is that a popular phrase in
Germany here's your burger still that's
what they say when you wanted the Booker
no I was just pantomiming skits from
American culture no from American
culture my favorites yeah like I said
what do you mean Oh like in seems like
like a yeah like a scene I would never
say the word skit but hey can I get some
more water for you are you thirsty today
is that from a movie or is that just a
general thing you've heard it a tender
go that's the law every time yeah okay
what was your question
oh yeah we have it look on your head yes
no don't do it this looks like that's
touching your face right in your face
yes some chuck are on the live stream
this whole side of his face is red Joe
small Pines I have creams I've lots of
creams I can apply creams are send your
well wishes we're gonna set up a
GoFundMe page to fix Flula smallpox
please send your donations if it's just
cents please
we'll be on the stream all night till we
raise the $40 yeah we won't stop soon
enough okay attractive thank you mother
you know marina you were you were you
were down at comic-con
today yes first day you're a little bit
like I don't know what this is all very
new to me and then I'm slowly getting
into it today I just went for it
took the deep dive into the con yeah
it's exciting it's fun there's a lot of
games out there to play you saw some
amazing cosplay stuff amazing stuff yeah
I was exciting yeah okay who's got more
of your cosplay thing let's take a look
at that this is you with some
stormtroopers I like that one of the
stormtroopers the very beautiful one it
refuses to put a helmet on yeah those
women that kind of stands up on the wall
she doesn't really have to move she
looks good already she doesn't have to
work for it you see me I'm lunging I've
got a really show that I've got more
than just a pretty face yeah but you are
out there with all the confidence in the
world I am making my shine I have to
these other ones and I think we have
another one let's go to the next slide
if you want to find a place to chill
this is a good place you know I I was
really active today so I got a little
tired and I figured we're not there so
mashups are pretty popular here based on
this character this is a stormtrooper
that also works at medieval times dinner
and tournament it's a samurai
I think it's samurai because that's like
a lightsaber katana yeah yeah did you
turn as you were lying there did you lie
on your back and just see what was no no
let's not go there you did not go there
I know okay I let's not go there which
is a different phrase it's so subtle
it's what really means less like you and
I only frustrating that we have to teach
Flula English live we're not gonna go
there I'm not gonna go there but it was
a good place to chill it was a good
place to chill you got to lay down for a
good 45 minutes on the floor there well
maybe - okay
minutes maybe two minutes you got things
to do yeah you don't have time we're out
there content this story it's yes not
very relaxing to have a sword over you a
lot out of there no leave it there so we
got one more slide for you a burn your
get away let's see and that's Captain
Marvel boot boot yes marvel jacket that
is a Captain Marvel jacket this is from
a designer girl universe
I hope I'm getting that right it's girl
universe it's a main from a young
actress that was concerned about
fangirls because there's a lot of
fanboys so this is for fangirls you know
cuz there's fanboys they have their
closest she makes them for fangirls you
know if you want to cosplay as your
favorite superhero and you don't want to
you know wear men's clothing or the
clothes worse that men make for women
which is like here's a leather bikini
that's how about you wear like a outfit
and going cool yeah you look so good you
know that the there was a black Captain
Marvel the black female Captain Marvel
in the comic books
no I didn't name is Monica Rambeau she
was a I think before Carol Danvers was
Captain Marvel they were people feel
free to check me on that I'm not exactly
sure about nudity but Monica Rambeau you
check it out you will be Monica Rambeau
MC you once they see that jacket well
that was actually me auditioning for
that part I like if someone's been out
there and they like the way I look in
that jacket cast me guys let me know why
Franklyn do this jacket make it to the
checkout counter what's this a purchase
this is a purchase thank you very much
Conan O'Brien this is a company credit
card purchase because I understand I see
it later because you headed over to the
was the overwatch experience or what was
this I did I went to the overwatch
experience where I actually got to be
very involved in the game and perform
like in this like circle thing with
actors who dress up the actors have no
words I'm sorry okay well okay well
let's take a look an experience thing
this is marina overwatch
[Music]
you're now dating both of those men both
of those guys the cowboy lifeguard was
that was that is that a character in
there for someone's not familiar was
that's just a guy that knew how to get
my attention
okay you look like the sheriff of Santa
with overwatch cosplay though is that
every time I've seen overwatch cosplay
it looks like someone making fun of
overwatch but it's usually like
something back to me please what I want
to say is like those guys were very
talented at what they do one of them
actually is a retired vet and now he
just cooks that's Ranieri I was the one
that was not a veterinarian okay
I just didn't know that's a fair
question I like of like he was he was a
soldier a zoo but now he just cook
people he had like salt and pepper on
his belt like a fanny pack was
spinderella in the pocket as well oh my
oh so pleased by her joke I've never
seen someone so happy Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
cultural references going this way he is
dressed up as a chef are you saying that
he is an actual chef chef's now because
he's no longer a soldier okay so this is
his thing is that he goes around any he
grills he grills things and then you
just pulled him into this thing I pulled
him in that kitchen well you know he
that's what he does in the video gamer
girls food that's his that's his magic
power yep okay and so you took the deep
dive this is like a full-on experience i
won did you see they're all in your
honor um you know I've been training so
that's all me did you see my stance I
had my boxing stance oh I saw that
posted on the the the at Kona Khan
account and I was legitimately surprised
I was like whoa she's in her blood yeah
you coming back next year yes
yeah I'm yes Queen so you guys are going
out there tomorrow we are going out
there tomorrow you're going out to see
tomorrow I think I have it
Shazam you wanted to see Shazam yes with
Shaquille O'Neal oh no no that's
different Shazam that's a Zachary Levi
right and the cast of Shazam Chuck down
there is this a panel do you know yet
I don't exactly know but I hope I do get
to meet someone from Shazam a celebrity
sort of like Joel Joel's been hogging
all the celebrity I can't believe you
guys like buying any celebrities you're
helping to hunt down I'm looking for
Danny DeVito's cousin and nephew are
both here and I want to find them very
much how do you know that they're here
it's kind of fun with them both on insta
okay and what excites you about them
they are nice
okay he's a simple man with simple
player not a Danny DeVito fan look what
I love tiny - have you seen twins
absolutely
we could play friends oh absolutely
that would be a good no I would evolve
Danny DeVito's work twins stands out to
you twins
what do you like about that movie Flula
because there are two boys who are twins
but they don't look like they don't look
like twins isn't it good
Oh before I get you got it you got a pin
oh right I got a pin today nice would
you want to see it yes what is this this
is what it is
pull that up right here Oh what is it
you know why I don't really know did you
win it ah
they gave it to me because I played at
the overwatch oh this is what you get
when you hang out with two guys for too
long all right so let's just all go
through our pockets and see what we
could find it see if we could well
random things are in our pockets that's
what this shows devolved on to I have a
receipt you've ever seen chipolte wallet
oh yeah I have a bar that show the
branding of it but I do have a bar I
love that specific brand of granola bars
the second you put in your pocket I've
come out so
if some currency that's that's the
dollar efforts of six dollars I can hear
the comment section now what is the show
they're going through his pocket we
don't know either it's a touchdown of
all things comic-con so Conan stops by
when it when he can and we're out there
this show is for people that may be
missed out on comic-con may be
interested in Conan may be a little bit
of both so they're gonna be back out
there tomorrow grabbing all that stuff
for us Joel what do you get where you
going to tomorrow no you always tell me
okay
a Deadpool living room I can't wait
Deadpool's living room eight yeah I love
it that have you seen the last Deadpool
movie I have I really I love the
Deadpool movies because you you really
get a taste of those d-list x-men
characters in the Deadpool movies I
never thought I'd see Domino in a film
and it's really exciting as a wireless
celebrity that excites okay living room
iconic do you know at all is that
something yeah it's like the he lives
there who's the one that the right well
it's Michelle Michelle is it the word
from Star Trek
that's in in debt living room the
girlfriend the blind landlady about this
is why I asked you
I specifically find out tomorrow and
I'll report back why the living room I
think I know because that's where he
hangs out with his girlfriend okay oh
yeah living room is actually very
important relationship study I was down
in the in rehearsal and then I went down
to the to the green room
and you know I was pretty excited about
what I found down there tomorrow on the
show the cast of glass is on but I went
down there didn't really see anyone
immediately but so pretty exciting
here's what I here's what I found yeah
that's some mayonnaise sandwiches wait a
minute little bit to your right is
actually Samuel Jackson samuel l.jackson
okay did you know that well that makes a
lot of sense now but you know excited
about it wasn't a Kangol I didn't
recognize him
so sandwiches do look delicious I must
tell you see him at a crushed velvet
yeah this was mayonnaise on just over
boiled egg whites
or can you say lunch breakfast and
dinner lunch breakfast and dinner yes
thank you say word yeah yes oh yeah I
got what I needed
I think sit can we zoom out again I did
notice another person with a very high
star meter rating okay it zoomed to the
other side yes it looks like as a man
who smells the dead the dead people John
McClane he's these dead people like that
he even smell the dead literally any of
us that does a strange twist of the fin
because everyone can probably yes that
is actually one of the regular sensitive
serve those sandwiches to anyone behind
you or no I did not know surprisingly no
one wanted to touch the gray on white
sandwiches that are downstairs in the
green room for that in the morning I
went down to the mr. Mercedes exhibit so
more for your exhibit thing here's me
down at the mr. Mercedes hey guys Moses
storm here at the mr. Mercedes
experience for the audience Network show
mr. Mercedes and despite popular belief
mr. Mercedes is not about a guy in
Glendale with dealer plates that drives
his Mercedes way too fast the
residential streets his head inside
you need the trigger can gonna pick up
the glowing Sears catalog
these trigger and get out though here we
go dear diary why do I live in such
harsh conditions
when we got in here I'm gonna do a shot
you and you like do some experimental
drug blue this just adderall dissolves
in water what study to study how many of
these do not supposed to have and I'm
addicted to rinse drinks in the
beginning it looked like you were just
organizing your file cabinet and then
you went from kool-aid it was almost
like too immersive of vr where it was
like oh okay these are just real chores
I need to do at home
you were playing like Assassin's Creed
there was like one level will you just
like deliver letters and like yeah this
is just like I'm doing this fictional
characters errands all I can fall out
you just end up building a house forever
this law and then you have to pay
property taxes on that house and get
into that put in the lighting yeah
Mercedes exhibit oh yeah Wow the Stephen
King novel so bored by a sentence in
just one word oh I loved it yeah loved
it yeah bridges tomorrow he's in fun
fact about the syringes all the juice in
there tasted like plastic syringe hmm so
they'll be out there tomorrow at Comic
Con again grab more of that stuff and
posting it on at Kona con there's ticket
giveaways there's there's all this crazy
stuff going on you guys are doing
meetups that people want to meet them
and you're trying to get into stuff
we'll report back with them tomorrow
we'll see stuff posted on at Kona Con
and make sure you're tuning in to
tomorrow show I know we're live right
now but the show airs tomorrow it's the
cast of glass I have it right here Bruce
Willis Samuel Jackson Sarah Paulson and
Shyamalan on the show tomorrow night
make sure you want is on the show was
with four hours yeah
well I'm thinking those syringe shots
are really okay thank you guys so much
for watching we will see you tomorrow
for another live stream of all things
comic-con good night bye
[Music]